Speaker 1: So now let's look at Tucker Carlson's
show from last night.
Understand the signal boosting of these right
wing conspiracy theories.
For months, Tucker has been saying on his
show without evidence the FBI did the Trump
riots.
He's just been repeating that, repeating that,
repeating that he eventually gets on this
idea of Ray Epps, Ray Epps, the Oath Keepers
militia guy is a fed.
Or a confidential informant, which is a completely
different thing.
Ted Cruz gets sucked into it because Ted Cruz
says the wrong thing about the Jan. six rioters
being terrorists, and he has to go on Tucker's
show and apologize.
At which point Tucker starts talking to him
about Ray Epps.
Then Ted Cruz does his good deed of the day
and talks about Ray Epps during a Senate hearing
yesterday.
And then we go to last night on Tucker Carlson's
show, where Tucker then signal boosts it even
more.
Here is Tucker Carlson continuing the Ray
Epps conspiracy theory.
Speaker 2: And while we're at it, here's something
else that's confusing.
Epps is a longtime right wing activist.
As you know, he urged protesters to riot.
True video from January six shows him at the
forefront right in front of the Capitol, appearing
to usher others inside.
So he wasn't just someone who was there.
He was going to be the central figure there.
Speaker 1: He was not the central figure.
He obviously was not the central figure.
And only if you believe that does any of the
rest of this even makes sense.
If you listen to this critically, you go,
Wait, Ray Epps was a central figure.
It's not clear Ray Epps actually committed
any crimes at the Capitol.
Speaker 2: And yet Democrats, for reasons
that aren't at all clear, suddenly seem highly
protective of ray apps.
They don't want you to criticize him.
Adam Kinzinger described Ray Epps today as,
quote, nothing but a January 6th protest attendee.
Speaker 1: And remember, he says Democrats
don't want you talking about him, but Adam
Kinzinger is a Republican.
Speaker 2: Really nothing but an attendee.
He is, of course, the opposite of that of
everyone there.
Ray Epps is the one you should be maddest
at if you were in the Democratic Party.
Speaker 1: What about Trump?
Speaker 2: And yet they're telling you he
was an attendee, not an insurrectionist, not
a terrorist, just an attendee, another engaged
American exercising his constitutional rights.
Speaker 1: Now, by the way, I haven't found
any Democrats saying that Ray Epps is a, you
know, disgusting right wing dude who was there
the day before talking about going into the
Capitol that I'm not calling him.
I'm not saying anything positive about him
other than the argument that he's a Fed is
not based in any fact.
Speaker 2: That's a huge change.
It's a bizarre it doesn't make any sense at
all.
So what's going on here?
Yeah, something is, that's for sure.
And one last question.
The committee has assured us that Ray Epps
wasn't quote employed by working with or acting
at the direction of any law enforcement agency.
OK.
But why did the committee stop there with
a committee?
Be willing to broaden that statement and affirm
in writing.
The Raps wasn't working with any government
agency, law enforcement or otherwise.
Speaker 1: That's a very typical conspiracists
thing also, which is no matter what information
you eventually get from people you say it's
not comprehensive enough, it's not full enough.
They will never be satisfied with it.
And Tucker continued This I mean, it's like
a lot of Ray Epps stuff on his show.
Speaker 2: It's wild.
In other words, they really expect you to
believe that quote.
I simply don't have any information at all
that individual.
So the DOJ knows nothing about ray apps, the
guy on the most wanted list right now.
Speaker 1: That's also not true.
We have a combination of statements, including
that he is not working for the FBI.
And when Ted Cruz asked some of his questions,
the answers were, I can't speak about individuals
in this way, and that would be the answer,
no matter who the individual was.
Speaker 2: That's absurdly false.
And as if to underscore how absurdly false
it is within a short time, Democrats in the
Jan. six committee released a statement claiming
that actually they'd already interviewed Wray
apps, and anyone who still has questions about
his behavior on January 5th or 6th is a dangerous
conspiracy theorist quote, Mr. Apps informed
us.
The committee said in a statement today that
he was not working with, employed by or acting
in the direction of any law enforcement agency
on January 5th or 6th or at any other time,
and that he has never been an informant for
the FBI or any other law enforcement agency.
End quote.
Wow.
Bombshell looks like case closed.
We can forget about wraps, though.
Speaker 1: Then of course, here it's when
the denial is not a good enough denial.
So these are indefensible arguments from Tucker.
You can, and which is common of conspiracy
theorists.
There is nothing you can present because evidence
in favor is evidence in favor, and evidence
or statements against are also evidence in
favor, either through to their due to their
alleged incompleteness or specificity or whatever
the case may be.
So my instinct is that these people will never
be satisfied with the Ray Epps thing.
But look at the the way that Tucker was able
to use Ted Cruz to talk about this on national
television during a Senate hearing.
It's incredible stuff.